hi I'm Robert Cogburn lead game designer
at Naughty Dog the uncharted 4
multiplayer beta is out now and runs
until December 13th one of the cool new
features an uncharted 4 multiplayer is
sidekicks sidekicks come in a variety of
classes and while they're not controlled
by real players they can definitely turn
the tide of the battle and get you out
of the pitch like mystical xand heavy
weapons sidekicks are purchased from the
in-game store during a match the Savior
serves as an AI controlled medic
charging into battle at your side and
armed with a par 5 and spare ammo
saviors can revive you or your allies
went down as well as provide extra
ammunition and a reduction on the
cooldown timer of your gear like your
nades mines and ce4 we're saviors follow
you into battle snipers stick to the
location you decide useful for taking on
multiple opponents or protecting map
corridors from charging enemies the
sniper will down unwary opponents ready
this also creates a useful distraction
for flanking enemies
the hunter sidekick does exactly what it
sounds like hunts your enemies hunters
will immediately begin chasing down the
nearest opponent trapping them in the
trophy this allows you time to track
down the enemy and take them out without
much of a fight Hunter's aren't
invulnerable though while they are the
fastest sidekick in the game a focused
assault can bring them down before they
get their hands on you the heaviest
class of sidekick routes are covered in
plate armor and scored a minigun players
caught in their spray volts will be down
quickly allowing you to turn the tide of
an uneven skirmish or overwhelm a set of
vulnerable opponents most importantly
brutes can absorb a lot of damage acting
as a great distraction for flanking or
flame all this armor and firepower does
come at a cost of speed brutes are slow
they can be outmaneuvered and flanked by
coordinated team just don't forget the
enemy is out there two sidekicks can
complement a variety of play styles find
the sidekick that fits your play style
best thanks for watching and I hope to
see you out there in the beta